[Music]
on this sunday night inconsistent border
rules
the confusion and chaos for canadian
travelers i was shocked when i heard
that they're telling you you're going
into 14 days quarantine plus the
beleaguered border towns losing business
having that turned off or certainly
restricted has a big negative effect on
tourism russian brinkmanship troops move
in to coerce ukraine we are very
concerned the world's response to
vladimir putin's gambit no warning a
lava dome collapses in indonesia
the search for survivors after a deadly
eruption and the salvage operation
coming to terms with loss in
flood-stricken bc
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us in less than 24 hours the u.s will
impose new travel requirements on
international travelers flying into the
country and there's no exception for
canadians the rules are aimed at dealing
with the omicron variant and although
there are no changes to the requirements
to cross the border by land as sean
o'shea reports border towns say all of
that uncertainty is hurting business
just when some people thought it was
safe to travel again and then all of a
sudden that dreaded seven letter word
omicron started creeping across the the
newswires uncertainty is back if it ever
really went away canadian border
communities like those in ontario's
niagara region more restrictions equal
fewer inbound travelers our concerns are
that border because you know 50 percent
of the revenue typically comes from the
usa and having that turned off or
certainly restricted has a big negative
effect on tourism the canadian land
border reopened to americans in august
with excitement the americans returned
the favor to fully vaccinated canadian
tourists last month they're still open
but in this pandemic there are no
guarantees the idea that we could
possibly be locked down again and
everybody wants to avoid that
might create some patience for increased
restrictions now foreign travelers
landing in canada other than americans
will need to get tested for covet 19 on
arrival and isolate awaiting their
results canadians going abroad will face
more testing too the fear of being
forced to quarantine back home is the
real worry that's really going to put a
huge stamper
on anyone who's thinking of traveling to
europe to asia south america wherever it
may be other than the united states but
people might be thinking well what if
they bring this into the united states
as well there's no perfect solution no
matter what they do someone is going to
be affected by it in a way that's not
great appearing on the west block with
mercedes stevenson the transport
minister said tighter rules can't be
avoided no doubt there's still
uncertainty in the air and i wish we
didn't have it however we're in a
pandemic a lot of people have that that
groundhog day deja vu sort of feeling
going and i can't say i blame them it's
confusing it's frustrating many
communities still haven't recovered from
previous restrictions what we're saying
is it's about risk management and not
panicking but planning let's have
coordinated planning measure twice cut
once communities wait to see whether
these new restrictions will be enough as
the pandemic playbook adds another page
sean o'shea global news toronto
that pandemic playbook is proving to be
complicated for canadian citizens and
permanent residents returning at land
crossings many of the issues stem from
the arrive can app as brittany rosen
reports it's not just affecting people
traveling for
pleasure i was shocked when i heard that
they're telling you you're going into 14
days quarantine ontario truck driver
nawaz khan says he makes two to three
trips across the u.s border each week
transporting building materials
but khan's fast card which pre-clears
him for customs when crossing recently
expired requiring him to drive to the
u.s in his personal vehicle to get it
renewed i went for an interview and
after 40 minutes interview i came back
to canadian side
when he returned border agents told khan
he had to quarantine for two weeks
despite being fully vaccinated khan says
he was not told by officers as of
november 30 all essential workers need
to upload their proof of vaccination to
the federal arrive can smart phone app
no exceptions canadians who don't submit
their information via arrive can won't
be eligible for exemptions and may face
additional delays at the border we
thought that if you were traveling less
than 72 hours no pcr test no arrive can
act the confusion is also being felt by
non-essential workers and those that are
less tech savvy older people with
printed copies are being forced to
quarantine where they wouldn't have to
if they had the ability to use the app
it's simply unfair border expert john
shields says there could be a reason for
this people have been faking documents
and identifying that they are vaccinated
when in fact they're not vaccinated and
i suspect that this is why the
government has said okay we will only
take the electronic
but for khan his truck sits idle filled
with undelivered products while he sits
fully vaccinated in quarantine waiting
for when he can return to work i had to
park my rig for almost a month
because of something that i don't
believe i have done anything wrong with
vaccinated essential workers being
forced into quarantine shield says this
could lead to supply chain issues ahead
of the holidays and for truck drivers a
forthcoming vaccine mandate in the new
year could further exacerbate the issue
brittany rosen global news toronto
a cruise ship with a coven 19 outbreak
has arrived in the u.s 10 people on
board tested positive prior to the
norwegian breakaway docking in new
orleans this morning after a week-long
voyage that made stops in belize
honduras and mexico more than 3 200
passengers will have to be tested before
they can disembark anyone who tests
positive will be required to go directly
home or self-isolate in accommodations
provided by the cruise line
canada's foreign affairs minister has
wrapped up meetings in europe where
melanie jolie shared canada's deep
concern for russia's military build-up
along the border with ukraine the
heightened tensions between the
neighboring nations will be addressed
this week when u.s president joe biden
holds a call with russia's vladimir
putin but as jennifer johnson explains
ukraine's military leaders say they're
ready for battle
tens of thousands of russian troops are
mobilized on the border with ukraine u.s
intelligence officials believe russia is
planning a swift military offensive even
putting in supply lines for medical
units and fuel to support a drawn-out
conflict what we've been seeing in
recent weeks is deeply uh deeply
concerning but the most important thing
is for russia to pull back the forces
that it's masked because
resolving anything diplomatically when a
gun is being held to someone's head
is very very difficult
ukrainian soldiers are ready for war
this military supervisor says he has
fighters who've come to the front line
for the first time u.s president joe
biden says he will tell russia to stand
down when he talks with president
vladimir putin tuesday
russia wants some control over ukraine
once part of the soviet republic but now
an ally of the west russia is demanding
the west stop ukraine from joining nato
u.s military leaders say if russia
invades they will not look away we are
certainly
committed to
helping ukraine defend its sovereign
territory as tensions rise lawmakers and
the biden administration are considering
economic sanctions and bans on russia
from doing business with u.s companies
to pressure putin to leave ukraine alone
it's up to us in the congress to make
clear that we are going to be diplomatic
political and military partners with
ukraine that we are going to provide
them with increased military assistance
so that they can defend themselves
since the start of the conflict with
russia in 2014 the west has helped
ukraine build up its military putin has
denied any intention of launching an
offensive but western leaders want the
russian military to pull back
immediately
jennifer johnson global news washington
the pope is again condemning how some
european countries treat migrants and
the politicians who exploit the crisis
for personal gain
francis visited refugees on the greek
island of lesbos for the second time
since 2016. lesbos is one of the main
entry points for migrants coming into
europe it was the backdrop for a
passionate speech against political
leaders who want to build walls to stop
them the pope went on to call the
migrants plight the shipwreck of
civilization
the taps are back on along the
trans-mountain pipeline which will be a
relief for drivers in british columbia
the pipeline had been shut down since
november 14th when the first of three
atmospheric rivers flooded the province
and destroyed major infrastructure up to
40 percent of bc's gas supply can come
from trans mountain the company says
there were no spills or serious damage
to the pipe the restart may help ease
gas rations still in place
in abbotsford one of the cities hit by
the floods the water has receded and the
true extent of the damage is becoming
clear in most cases it's much worse than
first thought many people have lost
nearly everything and as mike delay
reports that includes prized possessions
that have been in their families for
generations
as desperate as tony shorlumer had been
to get home he dreaded it as well until
today these roads had been impassable
flooded from the fury of three historic
storms
everything he was certain was lost but
if there was a chance to save the
artwork created by his dad 80 years ago
he needed to try
he's got like his
adaptation of gainsborough's blue boy
and
and the pink lady and so i'm going in to
see if if i can find them
he had to force the door open and
despite the chaos inside he found his
family treasures
heartbreaking doesn't begin to describe
the moment you have this
fingers crossed mentality that you're
going to be able to
in my case salvage my dad
but
it is
it's a fool's hope
they've been underwater and caked in mud
for over two weeks yet he wasn't going
to leave them here
like his father before him tony has
always been a storyteller good or bad
his family's history would get another
chapter
and when you know it wiping away the mud
revealed the vivid colors of the 80 year
old petty point
damaged yet perhaps not as broken as
tony had been moments earlier my dad
only gave me
two things in his
in his life
but he gave me
some friends and he gave me
give me
give me my name
he drove away today perhaps from his
home for the last time
the dread
replaced with hope
the flood waters are draining from the
sumas prairie but not as fast as
everybody would like the mayor of
abbotsford bc has said they can see the
light at the end of the tunnel but that
optimism doesn't make it any easier for
the residents who are returning
to all of this robin mike delay in
abbotsford bc
coming up a tale of two volcanoes
causing chaos
more incredible drone footage from the
cumbres vieja volcano on the island of
la palma a steady river of red-hot lava
is carving new channels through
evacuated neighborhoods nearly 3 000
properties have been damaged or
destroyed in the 10 weeks since it
erupted and experts say there's no sign
of it slowing down anytime soon
the death toll from an eruption in
indonesia continues to rise at least 13
people were killed and dozens of others
injured after that country's highest
volcano sent thick columns of ash into
the air and lava flowing down its slopes
mount sumeru is on java the most densely
populated island in indonesia mike
armstrong has the details
some of those who could return to this
village sunday to find much of it buried
more than a meter of volcanic ash and
mud everywhere
hunter
this woman says everything is destroyed
her relatives homes her in-laws home
everything is gone
in a matter of minutes it turned from
day to night witnesses say first there
was an explosion like a bomb going off
and then volcanic ash blocked the sun
suddenly it was all dark says this woman
like it was going to destroy the earth
mount samoro is more than 3600 meters
high the last time it erupted was
january there were no casualties this
eruption was bigger and too sudden for
people to react
according to indonesia's disaster
mitigation agency close to a hundred
people were injured some very seriously
and seven people are missing
[Music]
this man says what is important is that
his family members are safe but many of
his neighbors died
there was an increase in seismic
activity over the last few days but what
may have triggered the eruption
according to the country's geological
survey center are heavy rains a major
thunderstorm and days of rain would have
eroded and then collapsed part of the
lava dome over the crater while there is
now less pressure experts say there is
still danger more of the dome could
collapse
several villages have been evacuated
this man says there are about 350 people
in his evacuation center they need
diapers and medication
while some have been trying to recover
what they can
others will have nothing to go home to
mike armstrong global news
still ahead the worsening signs of
depression during the pandemic and the
demographics suffering the most
[Music]
you're watching global national
advocates are calling for better support
to deal with the pandemic's impacts on
mental health a new study found older
canadians in particular are more likely
to experience symptoms of depression and
as ross lord explains not enough people
have access to the mental health care
they need
for those who struggle with their mental
health the pandemic's isolating effects
make day-to-day living especially
difficult it was a challenge to simply
be at home okay and not being able to go
out into community and meet people face
to face nova scotia lawyer keith
anderson is one of many canadians trying
to ward off pandemic depression
according to a new study led by
dalhousie university researcher susan
kirkland the peer-reviewed study based
on phone and web surveys found older
adults were twice as likely to show
signs of depression during the pandemic
than beforehand and the symptoms got
worse in four out of 10 older adults
previous studies indicate the pandemic
is taking a toll on the mental health of
all canadians regardless of their age i
was sleeping very well during that time
okay i think that was part of you know
not the pressure but a symptom of it
perhaps okay that
is some challenges there anderson says
he's getting through it with the support
of his family and by working with others
who have similar problems but the
increased demand for mental health
assistance is overloading a system that
advocates say was already broken going
into the pandemic
there were hundreds of thousands if not
over a million canadians who lacked
access to mental health supports in
community all the more reason advocates
say to correct an oversight that
excluded mental health services from the
canada health act services like
counseling and psychotherapy
are really out of reach for many people
in canada who just can't afford to pay
for them out of pocket don't have the
insurance to pay for them there are
signs of change for example nova
scotia's new pc government has created a
ministry of mental health do swear that
i will in all things be a true and
faithful counselor nova scotia also
promises a canadian first universal
mental health care
a pledge many say has never been more
timely
ross lord global news halifax
up next the tiny island off the coast of
bc that played a mighty role in the
second world war
former u.s senator bob dole a giant in
the republican party has died dole was
one of the longest serving republicans
in the senate representing his home
state of kansas for 27 years he ran for
president three times and unsuccessfully
challenged bill clinton in the 1996
election dole a celebrated veteran
fought in the second world war in 1945
he was seriously injured on the
battlefield in italy and left for dead
he recovered but lost the use of his
right arm dole had been in declining
health and was diagnosed with stage four
lung cancer earlier this year according
to his family he passed away in his
sleep this morning he was 98.
this week will mark 80 years since japan
attacked pearl harbor changing the
course of the second world war what you
may not know is how that attack in
hawaii led to increased security
concerns along canada's west coast jay
durant looks into the forgotten history
of a small island off british columbia
that was fortified to protect the
pacific
december 7th
1941
a date which will live
in infamy this year marks the 80th
anniversary of japan's attack on pearl
harbor an event that put defenses along
north america's west coast on high alert
including here on tiny york island and
johnston straits a site the canadian
military had picked as a good location
for coastal defense before the outbreak
of the second world war that made the
war suddenly seem real
because
people on the west coast of canada
hadn't felt
the significance of the war suddenly it
the western side of the country felt
very vulnerable construction on this
coastal defense site began in 1937 and
during the war york island became home
for about 200 military personnel
docks were constructed guns mounted and
searchlights installed to help fortify
bc's coast they had an expert come in
coastal defense come from britain he
thought york island was a good location
because it's north of vancouver japanese
planes that might be
on route over the north end of vancouver
island heading towards vancouver could
be intercepted
so this is my dad here in the middle
schulte's father was stationed there
there were some long days isolated on
this remote island
told me about
them having a ball diamond so they
played baseball there other than that
i don't remember him talking about
other other activities these are stairs
leading up to the officer's quarters
nature has reclaimed a lot of the site
but some structures still remain a
reminder of a time filled with so much
tension when bc faced uncertainty about
potential attacks during the second
world war there was that sense that
it could happen
and so i think that there was fear
and you know there was some trepidation
that
they could be in danger and that they
might have a role to play
jay durant global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is the sunset on georgian bay we
would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thank you for watching donna friesen
will be back at the anchor desk tomorrow
and i'll see you next weekend
[Music]
you